warte mal ich glaube es ist spät genug
wir können mal übers kiffen sprechen
meine damen und herren ja eine uralte
debatte in deutschland die jetzt aber
wieder bewegung kriegt denn sogar
einzelne cdu-abgeordnete cdu abgeordnete
sind neuerdings für die legalisierung
linke grüne und fdp sowieso seit jahren
über 40 prozent der deutschen
jugendlichen kiffen oder haben schon mal
gekifft und ich sage es ihnen ganz
ehrlich ja auch hier beim fernsehen wird
man leider ständig von zwielichtigen
dealern angequatscht hier nimm ein paar
züge dann kannst du gut kannten
ja
hab auch bei ihm gekauft also beim
kranken bin ich bin nicht so sicher aber
was ich weiß von den gängigen substanzen
und das schließt legale drogen wie
alkohol und nikotin ausdrücklich mit ein
ist cannabis erwiesenermaßen die am
wenigsten gesundheitsschädliche es gibt
zwar einige studien die sagen bloß nicht
zu früh
und natürlich nicht so regelmäßig aber
das gilt ja irgendwie auch für alkohol
man muss sich einfach mal ja der
realität stellen sehr sehr sehr sehr
weit
ja ja ja ja sehr breit verwaltet das
zeug das ist was sie und andere länder
sind längst weiter mit einer liberaleren
drogenpolitik portugal zum beispiel die
zahl der jugendlichen konsumenten auf 15
prozent gesenkt kanada erlaubt den
besitz von bis zu 30 gramm und in
tschechien das kiffen nur noch eine
ordnungswidrigkeit selbst die angeblich
langweilige schweiz ist in sachen
marihuana viel lockerer als wir
überlegen sie mal die schweiz
ist so beneidenswert aber wer weiß
vielleicht ändert sich jetzt auch bei
uns was in sachen cannabis denn seit
september hat die gruppe ja eine neue
drogenbeauftragte daniela ludwig von der
csu sie hier
hier guckt sie sonst hätte gerade selber
was gekauft windig und kaum im amt muss
die arme frau von der csu sich schon
unverschämte fragen anhören hat die
eigentlich schon mal gekifft oder was
qualifiziert sie für diese aufgabe leute
mal ehrlich was ist die aufgabe einer
drogenbande ja ich nehme mal an dass
drogenbeauftragte den auftrag haben
drogen zu besorgen oder also sollte ich
verstanden
philipp amthor übrigens der einzige bei
dem sogar knallharte dealer sagen würden
die laster jugendschutz ja sicher die
frau ludwig von der csu war bisher
verkehrsexperte hatte mit
gesundheitspolitik nichts zu tun aber
das ist eine deutsche tradition auch die
drogenbeauftragten vor ihr hatten alle
keine ahnung von dem thema apropos da
fällt mir ein was gibt es heute
eigentlich in der wdr kantine eine dicke
kröte gras eine fette linie koks cool
das erklärt einiges ja ich habe mich
schon immer gefragt wie die auf die
orangen im ausland den blauen elefanten
gekommen sind
drogen natürlich trugen so warum
cannabis legalisieren wie sind die
argumente man hätte erstens mehr
kontrolle über das produkt denn auf dem
schwarzmarkt ist das gras in den letzten
jahren immer stärker geworden
zweitens vielleicht noch wichtiger wir
würden polizei und justiz entlasten ja
von 350.000 rauschgiftdelikten im
letzten jahr von 350.000 ging es bei
zwei dritteln und cannabis der
verplempern millionen für
strafverfolgung die nachweislich nichts
bringt sagen auch renommierte juristen
was sagt dann zb in die afg und der
polizistin ist es in der zwischenzeit
wirklich klar dass cannabis eine
einstiegsdroge für christel mit ist ja
er hat recht wirklich ich habe lange in
berlin gelebt und gerade im görlitzer
park stehen immer so
fleischereifachverkäuferin verticken
christel mit zu dem was denn
es ist so ein ernstes thema so die mär
von der einstiegsdroge gras hat die
deutsche hauptstelle für suchtfragen
übrigens längst widerlegt die ist
widerlegt ich finde wenn dann müsste man
alle drogen gleich behandeln aber ohne
alkohol ist die deutsche geschichte
natürlich praktisch gar nicht denkbar
wenn sich das mal vor ich meine die
deutsche geschichte ohne alkohol aber
dafür bekifft ich sage damit genug gras
hätte der 30 jährige krieg nicht 30
jahre gedauert sondern 60 und es wäre
auch gar kein krieg gewesen
alexander von humboldt hätte aus
südamerika keine pflanzen mitgebracht
sondern sie direkt vor ort geraucht ich
gehe noch weiter ein bekiffter hitler
hätte nur holland überfallen und es dann
gut sein lassen freunde und wenn die
väter und mütter des grundgesetzes
gekifft hätten sehr artikel 1 heute auch
völlig anders aus die würde des menschen
ist bohr gail hanusa aber das allerbeste
leute ohne alkohol ohne alkohol hättest
die csu nie gegeben
alkohol abzubauen man könnte auch sagen
es läuft für den sprit und das bei bis
zu 74 1000 toten durch alkoholkonsum
jedes jahr 74.000 seine horrorbilanz
komisch in der zeitung wer sich doch
immer ganz andere sachen also geradezu
positives aufschlag zahlen
eine flasche wein pro tag gesund
biertrinken gegen krebs jeder tag ohne
wein kann ein herzinfarkt risiko sein
gott ich habe heute noch keinen tropfen
getrunken
das ist ja unverantwortlich meines
herbst wie macht die alkohol lobby das
immer wieder solche quatsch artikel zu
platzieren das ja wahnsinn
tatsächlich gibt es und das jetzt
ausdrücklich kein witz eine stiftung
namens european foundation for aids
research die erforscht wie gesund
alkohol wirklich ist ja wir schauen mal
rüber in deren labor nach brüssel zu
doktor alexander wipprecht herr doktor
ich habe gelesen ihre forschung wird
allein mit einer halben million pro jahr
durch die europäischen bierbrauer
gefördert deswegen können wir doch
trotzdem seriös forschen hier zum
beispiel proband trinkt einen 84 château
latour erhoben von himbeere und
schokolade pro b ist abstinenzler und
sagt einen viertelliter sauerkrautsaft
noch sind jetzt nicht alle daten
ausgewertet aber wir sehen der rotwein
tracker ist viel jünger und deutlich
attraktiver dagegen hat ständig
schlechte laune und durchfall und unter
uns der riecht noch komisch ja in
wirklichkeit macht alkohol dem
entschädigt meine leber und erhöht
massiv das krebsrisiko das kommt in
ihrer forschung nicht vor so komplexe
zusammenhänge die will doch keiner lesen
vor allem wenn er besoffen ist alkohol
und da sollten sie als deutscher
eigentlich wissen gehört zu unserer
kultur das sagen politiker quer durch
alle parteien
wir sind jetzt bewiesen ich freue mich
wenn junge engagierte menschen heute
sich für bier interessieren wie er ist
ein deutsches kulturgut jeden tag zwei
drei weizenbier genießen einfach sein
meine seele sagt weniger als drei weit
sind am tag ist regelrecht gefährlich
wir haben das hier mal ein hamster
getestet schauen sie mal die nüchternen
haben es da hyperaktiv rennen das rum
wie vollidioten
der bgh dagegen tiefenentspannt class
ist ein gesunder welt wir dürfen den
standort deutschland nicht gefährt fast
nirgendwo in europa kommt man so billig
und so leicht an sprit wie bei uns aber
wir haben doch schon seit vier jahren im
bundestag die arbeitsgruppe
alkoholkonsum reduzieren was macht die
denn ja keine ahnung
wahrscheinlich spielen den ganzen tag
bekommen was in deren arbeitspapiere
stadt mal ganz kurz der schlimme satz
der verkauf von alkohol in supermärkten
und tankstellen wird beschränkt aber der
wurde dank lobbydruck sofort wieder
gestrichen
denn gesetze macht in diesem land immer
noch der spirituosen verband wir reden
hier von einem wirtschaftsfaktor
ich meine warum kommen denn die
touristen aus aller welt wegen beethoven
hier als ob man leute wegen saufen in
berlin gehört dass wir zum stadtbild
wenn ich da raus irgendeinem fenster
raus cook ja dann sehe ich englische
songs touristen die auf ihre art hallo
sagen jeder deutsche 230 liter alkohol
pro jahr im schnitt das heißt das sind
babys und frauen schon mit eingerechnet
130 liter das ist eine ganze badewanne
und da fällt mir ein es ist ja schon
november und um eine wanne kontakt ist
ja noch halb voll
ja das tut mir jetzt echt leid der welke
aber ich musste dringend weiter an war
es
forschen axl rose schlägt hierfür
weitere heute schon videos und klickt
moment
und klickt hier um den channel zu
abonnieren
[Musik]